there was someone in 2 Samuel Leeds on a
property investor making a lot of money
in property love to help other people do
the same and I've had quite a few great
questions from the previous week or so
from these Q&A Sundays so I'm going to
go through these try and answer best I
can while I'm answering questions if you
simply come up with a question comment
your question below I'll do my absolute
best to try and answer it on the next
Sunday's video so let's see what we got
we've got Henry Davis he says hi Samuel
on 17 I'm a big fan be watching your
videos for two years now can you tell us
about a deal you've done that has gone
wrong and also what you learned from it
this is because I I've only heard things
go smoothly with your deals which I know
is far from reality it's not far from
reality most of my deals do go smoothly
but you say for most investors I don't I
make maybe I don't know if they've been
trained by me their deals mostly go
smoothly of course some deals do go
wrong okay what deals have gone wrong of
course I've had things go wrong I think
more than anything it's not about the
the deal go wrong it's about the after
management of the deal going wrong so I
think one of the biggest things that
have gone wrong with me even in recent
years and this isn't when I was just
starting out is when you've got a
property and the tenant says that they
feel that you don't need a management
company so they'll okay I'll give you an
example and this even when you might
have seen this on the week the
landlord's moved them on the BBC
programme there was a tenant living in
my house this was in Durham and the
tenant was paying a reasonably cheap
rent of 450 pounds the government
reported be five five fifth day and she
was paying that there was no management
company so there was no official you
know management company it was all it
was from afar I got to doing it and the
set up was that she paid she rents on
the basis that any repairs and stuff
like that she would fix so she moved in
and she said look you know I'll pay for
50 but then if my husband's a carpenter
so if things go wrong he'll fix it in
the house we don't need a management
company house I sound so whenever I've
said yes to that what happens is they're
always bad tenants and they when there's
problems that don't fix it but they
don't
or two either and then what happens is
with the house a problem with a property
that's not reported leads to a bigger
problem like in my case in Durham it was
the roof almost falling in you know
leaks and all kinds of crazy stuff I
didn't know about it and it wasn't
reported because they were scared to
report it because then they thought that
I'd be like oh you need to fix it but
it's out of my hands Mike you're evicted
then you know so I had that happen in
Durham I had a similar thing happening
in one of my houses in Wales until I
finally learned my lesson and now we
have surveys go out to our tenants and
we we have good management companies
even if we get bribed by tenants but I
think that's probably the biggest thing
and then also with with pre buying a
house just make sure that you always get
you always get a survey on the house
because sometimes you can think oh it
looks fine but there can be hidden
things but I've never really been too
burned with that so but those are
definitely the things that can go wrong
so hope that helps all right let's see
what else we got we got man you Ella who
says I something or is there a mortgage
limit as I first buy to let on a company
name I heard you saying that there's a
limit at forty to fifty thousand pound
or sixty thousand pound a bit confused
there's so many affordable houses forty
thousand pounds and I watched you
demonstrating on a cross course
negotiating with an estate agent how do
you buy these houses as a company with
mortgage if there is a limit thank you
very much for your work I'm learning so
much from you yeah you're real I think
you thank you okay cool
so um alright so if you're buying a
house is an individual on the minimum
that you can buy a house for and still
get a mortgage on the house is forty
thousand pound if you're buying it
through a company I think he might be a
little higher I think he might be 75
although this this kind of constantly it
does change and it also varies depending
on the lender and things like that so
what I think your question is is if your
wanted to buy a house for 40 grand and
you'll want to do through a company ok
so the advantage to buying through a
company is that there are you can claim
the mortgage payments as tax-deductible
to be honest I would probably say buying
40 grand houses a fantastic thing to do
for your first or second
in third house but when you're scaling
up you're probably going to be looking
at doing bigger deals like 70 100 200
thousand because you don't want to own a
thousand houses that are all 40 grams so
what I would probably say is for your
first deal and I can't give you tax
advice because I'm not qualified to do
that but maybe even buy your first deal
as an individual okay what else we got
Sean Curran says hey Samuel are you
going to do an update video for helping
the normal guy become financially free
as I'd love to see how it went okay it
did happen I did drive to Blackpool I
did go and live with a normal guy who I
had no money and ill health bad credit
county court judgments against his name
in Blackpool I lived with him for a week
how did it go interesting here's all
what I must say I've said this before
when I hit a hundred thousand
subscribers I'm gonna put it out there
that's it so I'm really really really
close so if you want to see the video
just subscribe and make all your friends
and all your family subscribe and as
soon as a hundred thousand I'm gonna do
it I kind of just said that because I
knew the effort it would be going and
living with someone for seven days it
would be a lot of effort doing that and
I didn't want to do that just for ninety
five thousand people I wanted to do for
a hundred thousand so sorry to be a pain
that is coming out very soon I imagine
I'll probably hit 100 and then it's a
few weeks okay last question let's see
what we've got your this is from sh2
these are highly geared portfolios
things can go downhill very very quickly
um yeah there's some truth in that okay
so highly geared what that means is that
my I have big mortgages on my properties
the reason I have big mortgages on my
properties is because I'd rather borrow
money from the bank as much money as I
can then put the cash in myself which
means that I'm leveraged or highly
geared as some people would say the
reason I'm totally unworried about that
is because number one is even if the
house prices drop and my mortgage the
money that I owe is higher than the
house than that the value of the house I
don't care because
unless you're planning on selling the
houses it doesn't matter because I'm
still getting the rent
in fact if that happens if house prices
drop and there's a big recession
normally in recession when it's go up so
I'm actually going to be better off if
that happens so I'm not really worried
secondly as well another reason that it
can be dangerous to be highly geared is
because you've got loads of mortgages
then and then interest rates go up a bit
which they will
so when interest rates go up suddenly my
monthly payments go up and that could be
a problem
however you just need to make sure a
couple things number one is that you've
got a lot of cushion in the deal so that
the money that you're paying on interest
to the bank your rent is a lot higher so
there's a lot of cushion so if interest
rates are gonna have to go up so much by
the time you're out of pocket that if
they went up that high
we'd be absolutely doomed there's an
economy like it's just not gonna happen
so but but secondly some might say but
it might happen that and we might be
doing just fix your interest rates you
can fix interest rates up to 10 years so
I think that it's it's a risk being
highly geared if you don't know what
you're doing and if you're borrowing on
the wrong houses if you're borrowing on
the right houses and you know what
you're doing it's just the best way to
get wealthy and property so I'm very
proud to be highly geared and I will
always continue being highly geared
because I'd rather I'd rather if I
borrowing money from the bank and I'm
paying them 4% and I fixed it for 5 or
10 years like if you can't make money
it's almost free money well actually I'm
gonna flip it around you know your your
grandkids the person lost this question
are gonna say to you granddad no grandma
when the banks were lending we're giving
out pretty much free money what the heck
did you do with it and you're gonna be
like mm-hmm
thinking about no no serious the banks
were giving out hundreds of thousands of
pounds they were fixing the interest
rates and like three to five percent
what the heck did you do with that money
so I know what Samuel Leeds did Samuel
lives became financially free again and
again and again and helped other people
do it what did you do with it and and
what are you gonna say you're gonna have
no answer
so you right now you're saying all your
highly-leveraged that's it so if you
learned a lot I hope you did I know they
were quite technical questions so I hope
that I hope that was helpful comment
below and let me know your questions I
want to see all your questions below
I'll be picking some out to answer next
week and thanks so much for being part
of this I really appreciate every person
that watches every person that comments
every person that likes and subscribes I
really appreciate it I can't wait to be
getting some great content to you guys
real soon I'll see you tomorrow
[Music]